it's a climate Shakedown while Americans
struggle to heat their homes as the cost
of energy skyrockets Joe Biden and his
buddies at the U.N climate conference
have agreed to pay up to one billion
dollars in so-called climate reparations
support Nations and here's the kicker
the world's biggest emitter doesn't have
to pay a dime communist China could
actually get some of this dough all
right Greg I'll go to you first so
communist China is the world's top
polluter he's gonna he's gonna she
whatever you want to call it is going to
be eligible it's his pronoun she that's
right
will be eligible for handouts uh and
Americans are struggling to pay their
heating bills yeah that makes sense
China you gotta almost love China for
not buying into the BS that we're forced
to I guess that's the that's the charm
of not being a republic or a democracy
you don't have to buy any of this stuff
but at least we could be smarter about
it but they're like the guy at work who
just sees through all the BS you know do
you think they're worried about trans
bathrooms or non-binary pronouns or
climate active activism I don't think
anybody is going to be gluing themselves
to a portrait of a great Chinese leader
just cut off the arm right and they'll
say here's your here's your sculpture so
I think it's a you know you know the
irony here is that they've created
probably one of the most influential
persuasive engines of political activism
in the west Tick Tock and they won't
even let their they won't even let their
kids see it because they know it's so
dangerous so they don't have to do
anything that we have to do meanwhile
they're pushing it in our country
they're pushing the wokism in our
country sure they are yeah yeah as well
as the fentanyl through the southern
border and the undeclared war Dana I
would just say a couple things one this
was a move that was I think was very
significant by the Biden Administration
it got hidden under the weekend but mark
my words imagine if you're a Keystone
Pipeline worker where do you get where
do you go to get your reparations there
are none and also who's going to oversee
the how this money is spent you think
it's going to be spent well we can't
even spend it well here in America look
at all the corruption that we had with
the covid money and the third thing I
would say is this was just a way to
pacify the developing countries because
it says the details to come that well
then never come what they should what we
should do is allow them to grow their
economies using the greatest fossil
fuels that they can in the most
conservationist way possible you know
it's
we're basically admitting that we are
responsible for underdeveloped Nations
not being as developed as they could be
because of fossil fuels and climate
change do you buy into that yeah
with all that money I think that we owe
something to Nations that are kind of
stuck in our through way I mean this is
what happens in the Caribbean all the
time Pakistan was the leader of the
developing nations for this they just
lost 1500 people billions of dollars
because of these floods and they are
less than one percent of the global
admissions to Dana's point she's right
details to be hashed out Congress has to
appropriate the money by the way and the
U.S and the EU have said that they will
not sign on until they know that China
will not be getting handouts out of this
because the U.N deems China to be a
developing Nation that's obviously not
the case when you look at something like
like this
um so we'll see if this ends up none of
that is linked to science you have to
have science
I want to know how you link the
financial punishment to science this is
the same thing they have with
reparations when you're trying to link
people back to who was a slave and who
wasn't Who Sold slaves and who wasn't
once you get into the nitty-gritty of
who deserves what it explodes good luck
trying to link Financial reparations to
Country to Country oh how much do we owe
them how are you going to what's the
what's the algorithm there is none this
is all just suck and then who do we who
do we owe it to the government yeah yeah
it's hilarious who do we pay Jesse many
sources inside the Al Sharpton
organization say he's very upset that
black Americans are not getting the
reparations and the climate's getting it
first Kerry is supposed to be our best
Diplomat and three weeks ago he said
we're not going to pay any climber
reparations right and three weeks later
we're paying it and the Europeans
stabbed Us in the back how many were
world wars have we bailed the Europeans
out of and then they go shiv Us in the
kidneys when the money's down sorry we
industrialized first Jessica are the
monsoons in Pakistan our fault they've
been going on for 6 000 years and by the
way Pakistan why are we getting the bill
they kept Bin Laden there for a decade
while we paid those guys billions in
money here and then all of a sudden we
pay for their monsoons that's not fun I
want to Brian Kilmeade I want you to do
me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now